Kingdoms of Amalur is getting a
rerelease EA games are back on steam and
our play for all interview with Riot
Games will give you a ton of insight on
valor and I'm Persia and ev'ry shear
saves day for Thursday June 4th you
heard that right Kingdoms of Amalur is
getting a rerelease way back in
september of 2018 THQ nordic actually
acquired the rights to the game and now
they re releasing it as Kingdoms of
Amalur re reckoning the product
description on xbox calm state 3
reckoning will release on August 18th
although originally it said August 11th
when the page first went live of course
the updated version is gonna have better
visuals and all of the previous DLC but
it also mentioned refined gameplay which
seems to be the thing the fans are the
most interested in if you played the
original are you looking forward to this
rerelease es subscription service EA
access is officially coming to steam the
announcement arrived through a graphic
that is on the EA games page on Steam
and it suggested that EA access on Steam
will work a lot like origin access basic
which also has a premium version the
basic version allows things like 10-hour
trials for upcoming games access to the
game ball and other perks while the
premium version is just gonna go ahead
and unlock those upcoming games in the
full the EA access title mimics two
console versions to differentiate
between origin access which is already
on PC and operates through the EA run
origin store some of its heaviest
hitters though like apex legends and
battlefield 5 is gonna remain origin
only when it comes to PC valor and has
officially launched and GameSpot has all
the insight on the newest mode a
potential console release and how
competitive integrity is playing a big
part in the future of the game during
play for all our very own Dave Jewett
sat down with Anna Dominic yuta producer
of valor in' and shed some light on the
newest mode spike rush which is the
answer to a shorter more casual warm-up
mode that a lot of players were asking
for it in the beta spike rush is erased
to four rounds compared to the 13 in the
normal
mode and it equips all players with a
random loadout every round and has
powerup orbs to shift the balance such
as speed boosts and weapon upgrades team
deathmatch is being tested but Donlan
explained that valor and should be
enjoyed and experienced a certain way
which means the mode may not be playable
anytime soon the same thing can be said
for a potential console release while it
is heavily requested and currently being
prototypes it will only come to fruition
if it does not hinder the gameplay
experience that means if riot feels it
needs to compromise on any part of the
core valor and experience to make it
work on console then it's not gonna
happen it's not a no for sure clarified
Donlon because she mentioned that there
are people on the team that are very
excited to prove its potential on
console so what do you think do you want
to play it on console or doesn't need to
be PC only be sure to check out that
entire valor and interview on
gamespot.com right now because it's only
one of many amazing pieces of content
that play for all is bringing to you
guys this summer don't know what play
for all is well it's our multi week
charity event that's gonna be the best
place for you to get all the latest
gaming news features interviews and live
streams we're gonna have tons of hours
of awesome content that's gonna feature
all types of special guests we've
already played games with the giant bomb
crew and Alana Pierce and there's so
much more to come so make sure you tune
in celebrate gaming with us and support
great causes such as black lives matter
and Cove in nineteen relief efforts
that's going to be all for our news
today so thank you for stopping by you
can follow me on twitter at persia
underscore XO and I hope everyone stays
safe and has a great weekend peace out
[Music]